They say Haiti is poor because Haitians
can't lead. That is a lie. Haiti is poor
because France made them pay for the
crime of freeing themselves. In 1804,
enslaved Africans did the impossible.
They defeated the Napoleon's army. They
ended slavery before America did. They
built the first free black nation in the
Western world. And the world punished
them for it. France sent warships and
said, "You owe us for the slaves you
took from us. pay or we invade. So Haiti
paid for 122 years, $21 billion. Money
that could have built schools,
hospitals, roads. It went to France
instead. Now the same country sent
charity and wonder why Haiti is still
struggling. You don't rob someone for
200 years, then ask why they are
struggling. This is how they broke
Haiti. Right now, Haiti looks like a war
zone. Gangs control 80% of the capital,
not street gangs, armies. A former
police officer named Jimmy leads an
aliens called G9. They call him Baraku.
He controls entire neighborhoods.
Government can't stop him. Police won't
stop him. Some police sell weapons to
the gangs. Children as young as 14 carry
rifles through the streets, not playing,
not fighting. Hundreds of thousands of
family has been forced from their homes.
Entire communities erased. Some
neighborhoods formed vigilante groups.
Regular people, teachers, shopkeepers,
fathers defending their streets with
matchetss because nobody else would. The
world watched this and asks, "What is
wrong with Haiti?" Wrong question. The
question is, who did this to Haiti? Let
me take you back back to when Haiti
wasn't broke. back to when Haiti won.
Before it was Haiti, it was called St.
Dominic, a French colony and it was
hell. 500,000 enslaved Africans walked
the sugar and coffee plantation.
Conditions were so brutal that people
died faster than they could be replaced.
Ships kept coming from Africa. Graves
kept filling. But here's what they never
mentioned. St. Dominic was the richest
colony on earth. It produced more sugar,
coffee, and cotton than all the British
colony combined. One small island, made
40% of all the sugar in the Atlantic
world. The French economy ran on it.
Eurobian coffee cups were fueled by it.
All of that wealth built on African
bodies. And in 1791, those bodies
decided they had had enough. August
1791, the enslaved people rose up. What
started as a rebellion became a war. A
war they weren't supposed to win. They
fought France, Spain, and Britain. Three
European empires sent armies to crash
them. All failed. Then came Napoleon,
the most powerful man in Europe, the
general who conquered nation. He sent
40,000 soldiers to Heiy, his best troops
led by his brother-in-law. Their mission
destroyed the rebellion, restore
slavery. The heightening didn't just
resist, they won. Led by generals like
Tusent Lovato and Jeanjac Desalins, they
broke Napoleon's army. Yellow fever
killed thousands of French soldiers. But
it was the fighting that made Napoleon
quit. He lost 50,000 men. His
brother-in-law died. His dream of an
American empire died with him on January
1st, 1804. Haiti declared independence,
the first free black nation in the
Western Hemisphere, the only successful
slave revolt in history. They did the
impossible and the world never forgave
them. France lost its richest colony and
France wanted payments. In 1825, the
kings of France sent warships to her.
The message was simple. Pay us 150
million France or we invade again.
150 million France for what for enslaved
people France no longer owned
plantations France no longer controlled
profit France would never see again they
demanded Haiti pay for the crime of
freeing themselves Haiti had no choice
pay or face another war they paid but
here is the trap Haiti didn't have that
money so they borrowed it from French
bank with interest that won its freedom
went into depth to its former are in
slaver that debt was designed to be
unpayable. For every year, 80% of
Haiti's national budget went to France.
Not building schools, not building
hospitals, not building roads, just
paying for 122 years. The depth wasn't
settled until 1947.
By then, Haiti was a century behind.
France wasn't alone. The world punished
Haiti, too. The United States refused to
recognize hasty for 58 years. Why?
Because America still had slavery. A
successful slave revolt was dangerous.
It gave enslaved people ideas. So the US
pretended Haiti didn't exist. No trade,
no diplomacy, no support. Britain and
Spain did the same. Haiti was
surrendered. Every neighbors wanted it
to fail. And when Haiti finally
stabilized, America came not to help to
take over. In 1915, US Marines invade
Haiti. They stayed for 19 years, took
over the banks, controlled the
government, forced Haitians to build
American projects. When they left, they
installed dictators who would cooperate.
The Duvalia families ruled for nearly 30
years. Papa Doc and Baby Dog, brutal,
corrupt, backed by the United States,
they stole hundreds of millions of
dollars. When Baby Duck fled in 1986, he
took the 300 million with him. Every
time Haiti tried to stand, something
pushed it down. In 2022, the New York
Times investigated how much France
actually took from Haiti. The answer,
$21 billion. That is the money Haiti
paid plus interest plus what Haiti could
have built if that money stayed in the
country. Some economist said the real
number is higher, $115 billion. Compare
this to the charity Haiti received.
Countries donate a few millions here and
there and wonder why nothing changes.
It's like draining someone's bank
account for a century then giving them a
gift card and asking why they are still
broke. The debts Haiti paid is worth
more than Haiti's entire economy today.
That is not bad leadership. That is a
crime scene. And the criminals never
paid. So when you see a video of Haiti
today, remember what you just learned.
The gangs didn't appear from nowhere.
They grew in the store in France
poisoned. The poverty isn't Haitian's
failure. It's two centuries of organized
theft. The kill isn't a mystery. is what
happens when a country is never allowed
to build. France took 21 billion. The US
took 19 years. The dictators took what
was left. And now the world sense
charity and wonder why Haiti can stand.
You can't drain a country for two
centuries and then blame them for being
empty. In 1804, Haiti showed the world
what was impossible. Enslaved people
could fight back and win. That terrified
the powerful. So they spent 200 years
making sure Haiti would never be an
example. They turned a victory into a
punishment. And now they pretend they
don't know why Haiti suffers. Now you
know. Share this with someone who only
saw the chaos. Subscribe to Antara
Studios. There is more they didn't tell
you. We will cover all of it.